also wendy williams is having a bit of a
moment herself right on the down and out
what happened with win oh i got to thank
we're doing this new thing i got to
thank hellofresh real fast thank you
hellofresh
was one of your resolutions this year to
order let's take out hello freshman's
everything you need to get dinner on the
table no meal planning all deliciousness
get 16 free meals plus three gifts with
code h3tv16 at hellofresh.com h3 tv16
thank you yeah so wendy williams what's
the deal with her she's like
she's having a rough time
the reports of her needing a guardian to
handle her finances but she didn't have
a new client no conservatory she's
denying the claims though
she's like has dementia and they like
throws a bank account or some [ __ ] like
that it's the exact same thing as
britney
ship arc
what
free wendy will great
let the one exit and a new one enter
into the conservatorship
just like we just exited afghanistan and
we're about to go into uh ukraine yes
nice a lot like that it's just a circle
circle of life
well anyway thank you thank you um today
we come before you we've been gone now
for two weeks i think it's been
our we had our son born baby bruce
beautiful baby bruce ela who just gave i
forget that you gave birth
you want us you want to stand up and
show off your fit and let them see your
um i don't want to you said anybody have
powers or anything
there's no no baby
also show off your shoes because that
fit goes crazy
yeah
you should know
don't forget it
i worry for you ethan for valentine's my
special shoes
you wore those for me
yeah
all right talk to me later
uh you may notice some people on set who
you're not familiar with
let's go ahead and introduce them real
fast because they're gonna be we're
gonna play the game after the break but
they're gonna be sitting here so
ian you decide uh um
okay so we've got dan
and this is my beautiful girlfriend
allison
allison who we love
yes
i uh how long have you guys been dating
oh
geez how long has it been since
september
september 20
19
yes something like that uh just it was
just before the
next yeah wait what
so yeah two years ish okay
so congratulations you guys seem to be
going great alison is a very talented
artist
uh and uh she's she's great
shout out do we want to give a shout out
what was that i don't know
my show's not open
is there is it getting double audio
right now
wait my mind where is it coming from
nothing's open on mine is it me no
everyone hearing dub i'm muted
was someone's audio just playing
it was coming out of my monitor speakers
is really [ __ ] weird which is why it
sounded like it was bro you gave me a
heart attack you gave me a heart attack
i still never forget yeah in a live
episode
that was one that was so long ago
where
my laptop
yeah i was playing it and we had double
audio for like the first first 30
seconds of the show it was so bad
i i [ __ ] up one time when we're still
on zoom and i had the
show open and it was like what the [ __ ]
is that oh you i've actually never
messed up when it comes to background
sounds i've never never done that okay
maybe
he does it every episode though
oh maybe i thought it was just uh
calling himself abs uh why yes
here who you guys probably know
well hold on we didn't we didn't clap
for allison did we yeah
oh we did i'm sorry
i just want to make sure everyone gets
the love okay
so uh lena who who uh works for us as
well
also fantastic
show them
thank you
um
why suppressing us ian
yeah
lina who works with teddy fresh and uh
and uh the podcast as well
is the greatest we love her
baby say something nice about her you
want me to say something nice about her
yeah we don't have enough time
no we have enough time go ahead go back
we got like two out we have plenty of
time all right
well this morning like 5am i
accidentally burped really loud on her
face
and she i'm like i'm so sorry she's like
it's okay
wow really that's more of a matter
so she's forgiving it's very forgiving
yeah that's it's a sign of a good
marriage yeah
i
yeah
you're totally i like blast ass around
you now you don't even say [ __ ] yeah
exactly
does it bother you are you just over it
um i guess at this point it's like you
know i mean it's part of my environment
it's like
you
see your door it's all the same there's
[ __ ]
gas everywhere
lena could you say something nice about
ab after that that semi compliment
i i don't know how to follow up with
that that was just so good
um he's just he's so sweet
and
he's a great adventure buddy that's all
that's adventure
you guys are always doing something that
you can't adventure buddy is good
i'm spontaneous i'm a bad adventure
buddy
no adventure
fantastic well let's move it on to uh
zachary hello
chantal
hello
how long
hello
tell me about your uh tell me about you
two how long you guys been together uh
well two years been together two years
we took a little break to figure our
stuff out and um we're uh two years
we're counting it two years okay yeah
and tell me about the break no i'm just
kidding
but um yeah
two years
i didn't know we were going to talk
about the break
um chantal also works for us and is
awesome amazing she just started working
a few months ago you're doing such a
good job thank you we would love to
welcome you to the family you're
incredible
um
now how is it a lot of everyone's
wondering how is it that uh
that uh um what is everyone settled for
zach not just kidding
i'm just
funny enough ethan we met through my dad
really
you met through the talk yeah you didn't
grow up yeah i was actually working um
for someone else and todd was working
with my boss and he was like oh my god
you got to meet my son
that's incredible and that actually
works yeah wow yeah that usually doesn't
work yeah and i i love her we live
together and we have two uh doggies and
then we have two wonderful dogs oh
one's really great yeah well that's the
start of a good family
yeah say that for ourselves you're
basically parents now exactly and uh
let's go let's move it on over to
cameron and love yes
guys tell us about yourselves
[Music]
since me and cam has been pretty close
lately we've been sharing
an apartment lately
that's a big step yeah very big stuff
you guys moved in together right wow yes
yes
uh do you have anything to add to that
you guys worry you're moving too fast
although we uh we're not together i wake
up every morning and say good morning
love
so it's like oh you guys got like a 90
day fiance going on because he's from
sweden
[Laughter]
that would be awesome i could stay in
the united states
get that green car buddy oh yeah baby
oh that's exciting you know
any interest in moving here love
permanently yes oh oh that was a quick
yes
anything i'm not [ __ ]
by uh apartment here when you propose in
camp you would live um perfect
sweden utopian sweden yeah you know it's
not it's not that perfect
you know
and i can always go back what do you
like about it here so much that you want
to stay just your love for camera yeah
that's
the only thing that's really it no i
just i've been loving being out here
nice and just you guys are a bunch of
[ __ ]
oh come on thank you zach why would you
insult us when you're
all right well that's nice we love
having we love having love here as well
loves a little bit of like an american
boo too
like a he's an american bill yeah the
way what's that it's like
there's like weeaboo for like for
americans that love japan right right
he's that from sweden to america is that
true love um
i mean
kinda i wouldn't say i
i i've just been trying everything
american when i'm here i've tried all
the fast foods almost i've saved some
for the show for me to like give a give
a figure test or rating too
uh i have some i actually have some
right here
which we're going to eat soon i guess
yeah
no that's a good one
but not yet ethan
come on now
all right well uh congratulations
welcome we love you guys and uh we wish
we hope it works out
i'll help i can sponsor you guys as a
marriage visa right
thank you ethan thank you
for us
sure absolutely i would thank you of
course i would wow
i'll give any of you away
ian and sam of course who we know
they're both on the show fantastic met
on the uh
debate the beige thriller
years ago
one shot what the bachelor with the h3
the debate the beijing
[Laughter]
you know iconic couple
thank you how long you guys been
together now
it's been over two years wow like coming
up on two and a half years
mama mia yeah
time flies and sam you moved here from
which state
georgia
georgia
[Laughter]
come on
[Applause]
yesterday she was going on about
we had the like a food spread for the
super bowl thing and she was just going
on about this like boiled peanuts thing
oh i hate that [ __ ] she was just
slamming
the what
that [ __ ] is delicious which one and i
think everyone here that tried it liked
it i loved it i somehow i missed the
memo i did not would you call it sam the
automommy of the south
it's literally just like boiled peanuts
in their shell in like a brine
and then you eat it like edamame
that's disgusting no it's it's not
they're like edamame which is healthy
and also tastes good they're like
through that
peanuts
it's so boiling
out of like a styrofoam cup and you just
get it on like the side of the road is
the best so you guys had i want to ask
you guys about your super bowl party it
looked fun what is it called the boiled
peanuts just boiled peanuts yeah there's
no name really boiled peanuts
yeah you know and you eat the whole
thing i think it's called blue penis
brother
hell yeah
they're called hell yeah
yeah you know in israel they do this
thing where they soak
almonds do you guys do that in lebanon
i hate it
said yes
remind me of that do you like that stuff
i'm used to it yeah my dad used to love
it it's like take something that's great
on its own and make it way worse
they always got to be extra overseas
right even the desserts have like a
bunch of fruit and stuff and it makes it
too much no fruit and dessert period end
of story
just so the kids hear me in the back
all right well every we've introduced
everybody
there's actually one more person to
introduce
it's the person that's going to be
uh hosting so to speak or posing the
questions for our game that we're going
to be playing today who's that
[Applause]
[Music]
olivia are you uh are you is there
anybody in your life on this valentine's
day i'm assuming not because you're
sitting
i don't want to use my apartment by
myself yeah that's what i was going to
say that's what i was going to say
i love the hair
thank you so much i needed to do
something
uh
you're away from us
yeah it's good i'm getting used to it
again i started crying when i had to
write my first paper oh
and you did it
yourself could have been here
and i did it well
that's good olivia i have nightmares i
have legitimate nightmares where i wake
up and i'm back in college
and i have a class where i just didn't
go to a class all semester
and i'm like holy [ __ ] i'm just going to
get a f what am i going to do yeah it's
crazy how they don't go away it does
kind of drain yeah and it's
it feels so bad
for the rest of my life
hate school
shout out to all the students out there
all right
well straight up the bat so we're going
to talk a little bit about the super
bowl and stuff and then we'll play our
our newlyweds games how well do you know
your couple here on this beautiful
valentine's day we have a lot to talk
about first
uh first of all we have this sandwich
should we eat this because it's just
gonna oh yeah all right so why are we
eating the sandwich
well good question sam ordered this for
me it's basically for me to give a
rating
this is a spicy one
[Music]
you can still love eating it
you want to buy it no
that air [ __ ] fried chicken holy [ __ ]
this is good
really
just from that one bite yeah
is it busting
so this is the popeye's spicy chicken
sandwich right sam
yes
yeah
this is actually the best
[ __ ] i've had right
really in your life
of all the fast food in america
who deserves fried chicken oh my god
i agree i agree actually this was the
sandwich if you recall that i was losing
my mind over oh it was yeah yeah oh so
oh my god this is delicious
and love you discovered you have a love
for fried chicken or do you know they're
coming here well in sweden for whatever
reason there's not a lot of fried
chicken you can get
it's like the asian type
fried chicken which
is kind of different but this like super
crispy stuff we don't have it at all
so
yeah i kind of knew i liked it though
but this is bus embossing
yeah this is the best thing i agree
isn't it oh yeah yeah i have some more
stuff if i just gonna eat it with
chicken nuggets oh my god oh my god this
looks so good
oh
this is the popeyes
loves this is possibly the most like
excitement and energy i've ever seen
from
this is a black something dip
what was it called
back in ranch
what is that
oh my god
popped out of his head
dude
this is so good
turn out of time
wow
[Applause]
what's this
oh i think guess something wait what do
you rate this family is that 10 out of
10. you said the nuggets were dead oh no
no
well this sandwich was 10 or 10 nuggets
9 out of 10.
oh okay
biscuits
[Music]
i don't like the biscuit it's all right
i give it
seven out of ten
nice that's popeyes
but you know
fries too fries really good too
wow
this sandwich was such a hit love yeah
that people were lining up together oh
yeah i remember that yeah fighting
fighting trevor fights breaking out over
this salmon
but you're not alone
i can't believe this like it's
unbelievably good
wow
wow yeah it does have like perfect
boundaries compared to either fast food
here it's like not not even close
and it's double sauced it's sauce on the
top sauce on the bottom by the way that
i think that's part of why it's so good
i think so too yeah sauce is so
important
pie goodness
what is that what is that apple pie
never heard that one
yeah
this is also above average pie wow
wow these
there you go popeyes
i'm
so glad i'm delivering a test all that i
ate all
live
dead air do you need a napkin or
something
no i'm good
i feel like shrek and you're in my swamp
oh god what is that from
your payday oh payday right no i know
it's me
yeah
so love what's your overall popeyes what
is out of ten tell number ten
just wow straight up huh no doubt are we
talking like the most delicious thing
you've had in your life or just compared
to fast food here in america well i'd
have to consider the best thing of my
life but i'm not sure i would have to
think about it but the fast food for
sure ever not only in america like
everywhere
damn yeah damn and popeye's delivers
well if america knows one thing it's how
to
make fast horrible fattening
we've mastered that
ela yes you gave birth uh what like ten
days ago
12 days ago 12 days ago
so how are you doing
okay surprisingly i'm totally fine
um
i still have some cramps
which i don't think i had the first time
but um
other than that i'm like totally fine so
it's incredible see pretty
pretty pretty good
it's incredible seeing you around the
house like
i go whoa you're so skinny
it's crazy how fast your body deflated i
know it's so wild
how how much back would you say are you
percentage-wise
um
it's very strange because i still don't
fit into any of my
clothes even though i assume you feel
and look like i know but i'm i guess my
body got wider so like it's gonna take a
lot of time to actually go back to what
it was but
i feel totally fine so that's amazing
that's cool
see see uh guys this was like such a
weird positive experience
just overall the baby's super easy um
i don't know he he just like doesn't
complain almost ever
it's a complete 180 from our first
experience
i was gonna ask that because i asked you
guys maybe three days after yeah we're
going and ethan made it sound like he
was just like the easiest baby yeah
that's that's been the case it's so
crazy he's just like
sleeps eats
we don't
so far he's not colic like theodore was
so right he eats and then he's fine
which is
life-changing compared to the first time
[Music]
and
he barely cries only if he's like
uncomfortable or hungry or something
and he's super cute i don't know
yeah he's still p he's just peaceful
happy birthday yeah he's so chill i mean
theodore's the one who keeps me up all
night yes
yeah
theodore is actually more difficult
right now i think he's going through the
terrible twos now oh yeah like um
it didn't happen when he turned two but
now he's like two and a half or getting
close to three but it seems like now
it's happening and
everything is like an argument and he's
stubborn he wants to do everything
himself his way
well in the world well that's
that's hard but he's like waking up yeah
some nights five times like every hour
everywhere we're coming into our room
being like daddy come sit with me yeah
and um so yeah bruce isn't causing any
trouble for anybody honestly
but um
yeah he's a super chill it almost feels
like the shredder reverse alfredo
personality alfredo is like super chill
and shredder is oh you're right
love them both yeah
of course
but um
yeah i mean it's been good you know
we've take we've spent two weeks of us
at home yeah and for myself it's been i
mean dude i'm my sleep schedule is so
absolutely [ __ ] i'm just so screwed
because like there's bruce who brewster
is not that bad like he wakes up every
three hours and needs to feed and then
you burp him for a little bit and where
when you put him down we're not
breastfeeding like we said so it's
easier honestly and those mom's helping
a lot too
yeah thank god thank god for your mom
it's [ __ ] insane i had a moment when
um she went grocery shopping or
something she wasn't there for a couple
hours and like
i immediately started to panic because
bruce was like not waking up and he was
supposed to eat
and he won't take the food
and then it's immediately like you start
to think like is everything okay no
really he's not waking up he's not
eating
like when was that
just one day when
uh
i don't know last week
and then when she came back she was like
oh it's fine he just kept the meal and
it's like okay that makes sense he just
keep the meal what was i doing sleeping
yeah
yeah you well that's the thing about
newborns you'll always be like is he
still alive yeah and you're like listen
to his breathing
because they tell you all the scary
stuff about like there's a thing called
sudden infant death yeah
they can't sleep on their tummy or the
side
and that wasn't always the case like
when we were kids they didn't know about
that yet but it's like you can't it's
just they suddenly died
sids yeah it's like what
syndrome right no sudden sudden infant
death syndrome yeah
is that a syndrome you when you just die
what kind of symptoms it's a good
question
it's not a syndrome that's just death
oh sids yeah there's the ass
so
oh yeah i got fake tattoos that's a
we did a two party with theodore yeah
dino it's a dinosaur it's a t-rex
honestly i kind of like it yeah me too i
looked it down and i was like damn i
look kind of fired yeah
i have a tattoo on my forearm yeah zach
thought it was real when you walked in
ethan got
i would consider doing this as a real
tattoo
pretty fine
yeah pretty fine
um
yeah it does look cool though
so let's see uh yeah you're saying about
your experience
what was my what was i saying again
what's my experience what am i where are
we no you're not asleep
theodora
the baby eats every three hours theodore
wakes up every hour
and then
i sleeping during the day and you're
making your h3 tv no longer
slash
climbing
so you've been doing those at night too
yeah but that so that's like during dad
time when everyone goes to bed
everyone's sleeping is that hard until
like midnight or one well that's why i
posted at 2 am for 5 am right by the way
everyone go check out ethan klein
channel
that also aka dad time
i've been having fun there since we
haven't been doing the podcast and i've
been posting and having a good time
there i didn't post one last night
because i'm sick from theodore not kova
did a test that dude went back to school
for one week and here i am feeling
[ __ ] already yeah this is sick
thank you zach
so that's it
so that one's good though i guess um
it's not always terrible like the first
uh the beginning of a newborn our first
experience was just complete complete
awful compared to this
wow it was so hard with theodore
because
like you said he was super colic so he
was spitting up all the time that's what
it means acid reflux in like a newborn
and then they dude theodore used to get
colic so bad he would throw up through
his mouth and his nose he would come out
like milk like streaming through his
nose yeah and sometimes it would be like
a lot like crazy yeah
and so his nose would get clogged then
he couldn't breathe and then he was just
crying and then the other thing is that
was after
we've talked about this so many times
but he was basically not eating for the
first week because yeah doctors
basically were wanted
eli to breastfeed so bad that they're
willing to let our [ __ ] babies starve
yeah but so
also compounded with the fact that like
having a newborn for the first time is
just so scary and you're so confused now
with bruce i really know what i'm doing
you know yeah i got a baby and i don't
do the whole thing you know you changed
the diaper you lift up the legs you know
bruce has been finding ways to pee on
all of us every single time we change
him it's crazy
yeah he's a nice superhero
he's a professional at peeing at
somebody definitely
absolutely
but you know everything everything is
good at home
i was considering taking another week
off but
i felt like we should
we should uh you know
it's kind of nice to get out of the
house honestly
it's like the first time i was in my car
see sunshine
yeah
i'm glad you didn't because i was i was
getting
[ __ ] scared crazy last week i knew
you guys were getting along
a month vacation for the holidays and
then right into another two weeks and uh
yeah by the end of last week i can only
play so many video games before i'm like
jesus christ i need to get out of this
apartment yeah i was rotting yeah
literally rotting
abe did seemed like the only one who
wasn't happy to come back
i mean he [ __ ] hates his job
no but like you seem content not not
maybe
i mean
i would because everyone else was like
i'm going stir crazy
i've been getting my ass beat for a
straight week or two sparring so uh
i don't know it's
exciting but it's also nice to just
sleep in and then wake up and get my sb
rather than go to work oh you were
training harder
i started sparring yeah
yeah
it was fun though friday i did good
friday was the first time like where i
actually really felt like you won whoop
the other kid's asking huh really
did you [ __ ] him up
his coach stopped it he threw in the
towel yeah when i celebrated i went to
arby's it's such a big commitment
yeah
do you regret taking this project on no
i mean so much work you see his abs
i did see the third strap
what do you think about it i saw that on
instagram i was like that's a bit much
but
yeah it's just a bit much
i mean but if you gotta want it yeah i
mean you guys just got more pull up the
photo someone pull up the photo of
baby's ass all right hold on
lina what do you think about the abs
i like it
of course and what do you think about
the the poster when i google instagram a
b this other guy and
antonio brown comes up baby it's kind of
weird
i always make a joke that i hate antonio
brown because i always want that add a b
yeah he's got a b on instagram
so a b posted this third strap on
instagram i was like what i was like who
am i following yeah this is thirst
i had the same reaction
[Laughter]
now those gray sweatpants maybe was that
just like what you were wearing or was
wait are you saying you can see a dick
in front of you kind of see his guy i
made sure you could not see a dick
[ __ ] [ __ ]
dude you're such a thirst trapper baby
i didn't even think about the sweatpants
angle
yeah dude
but you can't see anything
so wait you can't you're saying you can
see the dick no you can't [ __ ] i'm
not gonna zoom in i'm not to do that
i made sure you couldn't look you got a
big hog on it i got nothing problem with
that just a minute
yo seriously all of our girlfriends are
here abby hi
yeah what are you doing
look at this okay nevermind
anyway exactly
are you okay with him
huh
i am he's been working really hard so
why not show it off hey
look at that
show him my stomach the next day he's
like bro you totally photoshopped that
okay i did not i did not say that
did you confirm it zach yeah he's got
[ __ ] washboard abs dude i'm proud of
him i'm super yeah he's been working
hard yeah i mean that's how you do it i
can't knock the hustle man you guys left
funny comments love said delete this my
future girlfriend has the app
dan said babe get in get hey get up babe
get up new av their strap just dropped
zach just straight uh wants to [ __ ] you
no words needed
i went uh i went with ab to a training
session uh was it last week yeah last
night that was last week it was last
week it's all blue uh to film some stuff
that we will eventually be able to show
uh because we're kind of documenting the
journey
but we have to wait until
things get a little bit more solidified
with the plans
they still the data is still not public
right not public but within the next
couple of weeks should be announced
right
and there's some [ __ ]
big
people in
yeah orbit that are uh involved in this
yeah no it should be a good event
it's going to be a good and it's all for
charity not ace family charity like
absolutely
right yeah although let's see maybe i
don't make out like a bandit we'll never
see him again
this is the exit strategy somehow i
doubt that scammed
scam yeah
so there you go what quite a transfer a
three-month transformation though i
gotta say abby
yeah one thing like when i first started
i was so out of shape that it made me
realize i never want to be like that
again it's like i felt so pathetic like
i couldn't even do any jump ropes
i can't do it
but enjoy it now while you're doing
thank you thank you
by the end of the year you will be back
too
probably you'll be back
and we'll we'll all welcome you with
open arms thank you thank you
life's too short to exercise i'm just
gonna be honest there are so many better
things to do than exercise we have
finite we have finite time on this earth
and like peop this is what i'm saying
the exercise is such a conspiracy they
go
let's say you spend an hour on a
treadmill every day money even
it's not a conspiracy let me explain why
it's a conspiracy
okay thank you
you spend an hour on a treadmill every
day
yeah somebody got out a calculator
oh god
this is facebook live an hour every day
you should go on facebook
one hour a day what are you doing i
don't know it's a conspiracy wait and
hear me out
let's say you how long okay let's say
you live to be
85 okay 85 years old and used to
exercising every day since 15 years old
so uh
70 years of exercise 70 years
so 70 times 365 times 365.
and an hour every day
times one well yeah so that's just
how many 25 000 divided by 24.
what is it
1064
hours
right hours divided by 24 divided by 24.
that's a days
right days i'm sorry how many [ __ ]
days is that one thousand six hundred
one thousand sixty four days divided by
three six five it's 14 points
it's just a little under three years
three [ __ ] years of your life
walking a treadmill yeah but on page
four here's the thing will that exercise
extend your life more than three years
no
but that's the thing people but okay we
have a heart attack if you guys will
because you're slamming popeye's chicken
sandwiches
the thing that i'm saying
is that people need to consider
when they talk about we didn't we didn't
even account for leap year i just
realized this is
so unscientific
it's 14 pages
[Laughter]
for those of you guys who don't
understand the 14 page meme is from an
ethan klein video
we have the meme levels go too deep i
think if people exercise we shouldn't
try to discourage them
because it is good for you don't
exercise i'm here to say it
um
but what people don't consider they say
exercising adds on life but what they
need to know is that it actually takes
off three years of productivity thank
you
i'm not clapping
right something compelling to consider
ali says yes
there's a lot of final fantasy that i
could be playing
oh wait wait
the rest of my case there you go
and that's why i've decided never to
exercise
uh okay um
how are we looking here
joker brain should we do the zack joker
brain or are we it's probably about
break time of that well yeah we're at 37
uh the newlywed game time right yeah so
we should do the ads and then um
yeah we could do we could do either the
joker brain thing isn't that long let's
do
okay
so either before we move on any less
pregnancy comments let's see um
any word to the ladies people
considering giving birth you did this
one without an epidural
we again we told the whole story on
ethan klein channel because we've been
gone
so sorry if you guys were waiting to
hear about that so i feel like um
short version it happened super fast so
there was no time for our epidural which
we kind of suspected that might happen
but it was way faster than we ever
thought it could be yeah basically one
hour so
um
it was okay though you know it was scary
and painful but so fast that you kind of
just like
forget about it
it was so fast well if you guys didn't
see the video on ethan klein i missed
the pregnancy because it was so fast i
had to go downstairs and do a covet test
and by the time i came up there was a
freaking baby in her arms
it's insane yeah
i was like what the hell
yeah so go check out that video if
you're interested in the story yeah
but uh like i said we're on a two-week
break so i was like i gotta tell this
story now
uh
all right
let's do joker brain break and then
we'll do the newlywed game
oh you want to do that first i was
saying we should do the break now okay
let's do the break and then let's do the
newlywed game so we don't keep the
couples sitting here okay awkwardly are
you guys are welcome to stay though you
guys welcome to the whole show not
chilling yeah adds a little spice all
right let's think hello fresh
you know it you'll love it
let's see that burrito guys we've been
on break
either did you know that abe made this
burrito yes i did
this burrito uh i did let's see hello
fresh delivers pre pour oh no not there
with hello fred oh look at that
delicious burrito this was actually in
those gray sweatpants this stuff
did you take stuff
yeah it was it was good i remember okay
we'll never forget it because we can't i
don't know because i don't know what's
inside of it
did you mold it after your hog dude
dude zack chill damn
it was it it was tasty
anyways nutella fresh zach you gotta
chill dude damn
[Music]
i think i missed something zack said did
you roll it after your hog oh
yeah
anyway
with hellofresh you get farm for oh now
that's what i'm talking oh my god
yo who made that uh a
um fan on the discord uh by the name of
pterodactyl
therapy
if i got the wrong person i'm very sorry
but
we've got a bunch of
fans i've been sending in their photos
you can show them i'll keep reading with
hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
skip the trips to the grocery store and
count on hella fresh to make some home
cooking make home cooking easy fun and
affordable and that's why it's america's
number one meal kit
hellofresh delivers pre-portioned
ingredients to your door including farm
fresh produce that arrives within a week
so you get convenience without skimping
on quality skip the trip to the grocery
store and saving you the weight in long
lines
and ensuring
you don't waste money on excess food
damn that food looks so good is that a
flop
you nailed it sure is customize your
favorite dishes with their new hello
custom offerings by swapping out one
protein
or side for another upgrading for more
luxe experience or even adding protein
to a veggie meal
uh the that means more choices more
variety and more meals truly tailored
for you
we love
hella fresh
in this household
they send the box it's pre-portioned you
learn a lot so no matter your level of
cooking skills if you know nothing if
you're a veteran it's still fun
you can learn a lot in the process and
they make it so it's pretty much i'm
not going to say impossible but it's
really hard to mess up
you know
so let's not uh
let's not say impossible because let's
face it you know
everything is possible some of you all
are incompetent
i mean yeah and this and what did you
say
some some people are just incompetent
yeah that's what i'm saying you're gonna
[ __ ] it up and it's gonna taste like
[ __ ] that's on you that's on you
hellofresh is like can you not
[Laughter]
no it's so good it's so fun guys and
it's it's just it's a great experience i
definitely recommend it and we got a
great offer go to hellofresh.com h3tv16
and use the code h3tv16 for up to 16
free meals and three free gifts that's
hellofresh.com h3tv16 use the code h316
for 16 free meals and three free gifts
it's america's number one meal kit hello
fresh thank you
thank you
and now on to another amazing
brand hbo
max
hbo max has kept my streaming queue
stocked all year with all kinds of
amazing content but one thing i'm
especially excited about is all the new
stuff that keeps coming down the
pipeline
that is the truth hbl max is here to
stay they have established themselves as
one of the top streaming platforms i
would never ever cancel my hbo max uh
it's so worth it i'm always finding when
i'm stuck and i go oh there's nothing to
watch i go to hbo maps and i always find
yeah i just started euphoria actually
and so yeah i'm into it right there's
there's so many there's a new season so
i was like i never watched this show
just yesterday yeah
after the super bowl um sam was like now
it's time for my super bowl the new
episode of euphoria
i don't watch that
we watch it every sunday oh yeah you're
into that do you like it oh cool yeah
it's great i'm catching up then very
good i'm on season one
yeah it's like a long music video but
the the cast is so good like i just love
all the characters already and i just
started yeah it's great yeah
i like whenever ella finds a show she
likes though because i just sit and play
video games and
she's happy so if i have a shot to watch
i'm like the happiest person in the
world and then if i don't have a show
i'm like
yeah so happy wife happy life
and i just get to play video games
anyway season two premiere of raised by
wolves i haven't that show looks crazy
it's like some weird sci-fi one right i
have to admit i haven't watched it i've
looks really a couple friends that have
been begging me to watch it for a couple
years the new season got something like
rave reviews
rick and morty's on hbo math um uh
and
euphoria and peacemaker yeah dude
peacemaker also
rave reviews dude hbo max i watched the
first episode it was really good
feel free to check out the site and any
other new titles you're interested in
that was a note for myself that i wasn't
supposed to read
hbo max has all your favorite supplies
that still applies to the audience it
works hbo max has all your favorite
titles available for streaming they've
got something for everyone with
everything you love all in one place
uh plus you can download top titles to
watch on your device on the go don't
miss out on taking your entertainment
game to the next level hbo max is the
streaming home of over thirteen thousand
hours of addictive series blockbuster
movies and exclusive originals tre start
streaming on your favorite device today
sign up at hbom
dot ax slash h3tv and don't worry that
link's in the description
if you don't want to type out hbom
dot ax slash h3tv thank you everybody
some people in the chat are pointing out
uh smiling friends is also on hbo max
wait it is
that's right on hbo max oh that's good
to know that's great to know because i
was actually trying to find a place yeah
we want to watch it
love and i were actually just at the
premiere party this past
oh was that
very nice
cool
very congratulations
oh free and super good let's go
open bar yeah baby nice
i'm happy for zach he deserves it yeah
he's a good dude
yeah i saw i saw a commercial for the
smiling friends i was like oh wow
good for them
i haven't seen any episodes yet because
i didn't know where to watch it
but it seems to have a lot of have you
guys watched it yet yeah
no it's awesome highly recommend it
cam's a fan but i haven't seen it yet
but now that it's on hbo max i'm on it
zach
haidle yeah and uh michael cusack he's
also the co-creator he's a buddy oh yeah
we met him too
right yeah right yeah
i remember when they were just trying to
get it picked up yeah they've been
working on it for a while
well
let's do the you guys ready for the
newlywed
game
here are we ready
i don't know let me make sure olivia's
ready
all right
[Music]
here we go
it's the newlywed game she is posted by
olivia
olivia
olivia how are you feeling today
i'm feeling pretty good how are you
feeling today well i'm feeling love
feeling the love here on this
valentine's day
little intro by the way oh so roll okay
go ahead and roll the intro first here
uh ian thank you
i can't see it
[Music]
olivia go ahead can you do the game show
can you do the game show voice for me
please oh no oh no i don't know how long
it'll hold up but
everybody welcome to the show no no no
like everybody welcome to the game show
okay more like that more like that
hi everybody welcome to the game show
like that hey everybody thanks for
joining us though
you got good news
all right
the way that it's gonna work is i will
pose a question and one partner will
answer and then i'll post another
question and the other partner will
answer so you guys will take turns great
questions you're all right
all right we love it
the newlywed game
who wants to go first you're kind of
sound like oj sorry oh jay even said i
thought oj oh because he goes hey
everybody
i just killed my wife
it's yours
truly
see that's seth rogen laughing
right
i wonder
all right sorry olivia go ahead i will
go first
okay no you're good so question one
wait where
oh for for the guys i think no so the
way we're going to do all the couples
at once it's going to be if we go one
it's yeah it's gonna take forever so
just all the couples so yeah i guess the
question we'll do like the question for
the guys okay the girls and cam you guys
will have to someone keep getting
decided
who will be
um
i think just keep keep score for
yourself for like your own couple maybe
we could honor this honor system we
could all write our answers and then
show our answers one by one each couple
i can use points
olivia's got points she's got it i think
she's gonna use this i guess oh we all
have white boards
[Applause]
high budget high budget
we're up in the ante here okay
all right okay where's the where's the
craziest place you played you've made
whoopee
is that one of the questions that
literally is one of the questions on the
actual movie
that should be a question though where's
the craziest place you played whoop and
i made whoopie
have you seen that great clip where she
goes in the butt
i have no idea what he's talking about
it's a real game the newlywed game it
was a tv show oh it's an actual
clip where she says where's the craziest
place you've had whoopi mean sex that's
what they called it back in the day like
location and then the girl goes i don't
know in the butt
how [ __ ] awesome is that
okay go ahead olivia
question one for the guys
yes where slash when was your first kiss
and so i'm writing the answer
well you're all supposed to write the
answer and see if and then reveal it so
everybody writes yeah we have some music
please uh
i need to write it too we're both
writing everyone's reading and then
you're right and then you see if you
have the same answer okay
gimmick here so where is the first place
we kissed
geez
it's alone
okay let me think here um
how specific do we need to get i think
first kiss on the left no
oh just the location i think you just
other kind of kiss would uh
i think she would be asking yeah i don't
know one more thing like how specific
like the place and location yeah exactly
the event or yeah that could work too
you never know dan i kiss my own
handwriting i remember i remember yeah
you didn't tell that story i'm just i'm
just yeah
loving camera sweating right now i seen
the uh i just wrote a play
first place you made love cam in love
where's the craziest place you guys made
whippy
all right everybody have their answers
um yes
yeah
i think all right so ethan ely you guys
reveal first what you got santa cruz oh
okay i wasn't sure if we on the birth
right no we didn't we didn't okay
that's what i was trying to say what did
you write
i robert oh my god i wish
all right ally you and me yeah what do
we got reveal
my house
oh
wait a minute i was specific i said on
the porch
those are wrong locations oh my god
you're right i was right
see now you went too specific that's why
that's why i was wondering how specific
well don't worry you were broad as hell
and you still got it wrong i know
you could have been more broad but
that's what i was thinking about
happening
uh ab lina what you got
house
uh uh oh that doesn't look like we moved
out of deer where you don't have to lie
anymore
the real answer lena gave the arab
answer at our engagement party
i don't know why you're still playing
are you serious with your engagement
party
that was your first kiss lina get these
nuts
jesus
well you guys gotta you guys have
clearly got that wrong
your engagement party
yeah let me tell you
that it was in front of my front door
she was sitting on my lap
no i'm just i'm i'm kidding i'm kidding
but okay wait did your parents your
parents really think that you you guys
didn't kiss to your engagement party
absolutely
her parents not my friends like you guys
were already you were getting married
now you can kiss finally yep we're just
studying at the library together for
years
[Laughter]
wow couple students interesting that's
pretty good sorry cat's out of the bag
to lean his family all right well so far
that's uh nobody scored a point
unbelievable technicality yeah uh i
guess uh zach and chantel what you got
her bedroom on her bed
my bedroom okay they nailed it that's a
point do we have like a point sound
effect on the bed
straight
straight to business straight to
business huh guys
[Laughter]
none needed all right and cam what do we
got go ahead
nowhere nowhere
nowhere is it yet to be decided
yet to be decided
i think
yeah i think they get a point okay
sam and ian what we got
in the hilton parking lot
in the whole hotel hilton parking lot
they got both roles
specifically the elton parking lot
yes why don't you guys say just like in
the bathroom at mcdonald's
well that's a point so uh
so
is that because the bam you were
visiting
it was the my first visit here yeah okay
that's that then then we understand
the hilton parking lot let's go where it
all goes downhill
we're all good memories are made
the hump and hilton all right so three
points for the couple's in the back i
can't believe you said birth right ela
you wouldn't you wouldn't
we can't start arguing now about every
answer
i'm just kidding also i
have mom brain right now which is an
official thing
oh well i have ethan
which is a permanent thing
all right next question wow what an
exciting first round folks discovering
here on the newlywed game
olivia go ahead
what is your partner's coffee order
oh
that's easy right yeah
that's a good question though
thank you very much
did you make these questions olivia
i went through old boyfriend tags and
then just like gathered a bunch of stuff
oh good job
[Applause]
all right
you got yours all right gilas is black
with lots of cream no sugar ever
and i wrote hot coffee with cream no
sugar
so wait am i answering for you
technically you're supposed to yes but
it's okay if you both got each other you
can confirm whether the other person no
no we're we both get the same order oh
well that's why i don't know what you
would get so but am i supposed to whose
turn is it
uh right we didn't establish it i don't
think that's what i'm saying turns right
yeah it's fine no no no no no you gotta
get the same answer it doesn't it
doesn't matter yes it does you have to
know who you're writing for otherwise
you'll write two different answers no i
thought it's for well what are you doing
no he's technically right you it should
have been like
for the guy or for the girl what are we
doing oh wait oh yes okay so what did
everyone do no i just wrote her order
like it is confusing all right hold on
just olivia who are we answering for
okay we could do okay
the person who
answered
last time who
answered for the other person
that person is the order that can you
can you
it's the girl in the couple's order
that's it that's the answer technically
we could do both at the same time and
just write oh my god no we're done
it's the exception for this one okay the
girl and the answer so right all right
we both got it right everyone has do you
have to get both right i get bonus
points for getting dan's right you have
to get both ways
i answer
hers and she answers yeah okay for this
round you have to get both right or
you're banished okay and that's the only
way to drink your coffee by the way
thank you thank you thank you everybody
all right go ahead dan
oh a b
all right go ahead you got it you got to
read your answer because there's people
listening she's not big on coffee not
big on coffee
she said that's true is that how you
take your coffee not big on coffee i
mean she doesn't have an order she
doesn't like she gets like uh what are
they called refreshers
yeah so why don't you write that that's
not coffee
[Music]
is that the right answer lena yeah it is
okay okay and lena iced two refreshers
and for a bee i put down iced or frozen
with creamer sugar let's see
it makes me use the bathroom a lot but
that is true
[Laughter]
okay
all right wow look up look at you guys
coffee dan go ahead
we've got some conspiring going on
yeah i uh ally gets a iced americano
with soy milk with extra ice and one
pump of uh classic sweetener
it's very specific
many times so i've got it uh memorized
at this point is
dan likes a
grande hot soy latte or
if he's early enough to get the blonde
roast he gets dripped with soy that's
right you like that drip soy what's that
blonde drip that drip soy no
blonde
roast with soy there's no such thing as
it did you say it dripped soy
drip
drip coffee with soil
zachary go ahead
so i said zach likes black coffee
on a hot day he likes cold black coffee
with a cig
and on a cold day he likes a hot black
coffee with a cig
so basically
we like it hot we like it cold big on
the side what do we think zach
she definitely got that yeah
with the [ __ ]
and then for her it's oat milk sugar
mc2ill coffee every morning because i'm
hurt zarista
hey can you um
hey b why are you dying
what's so funny av you've got something
[Laughter]
all right go ahead uh love and
cameron all right love gets a monster
energy fico he doesn't drink coffee
monster energy
oh my god
hell yeah black with nothing so they're
calves or
cam black
love nothing well you get a monster
interview that's no he's right
they're on the board yeah yeah give it
to give him the point yeah they're
crushing it so far oh yeah dynamic duo
all right
so you guys yeah okay
so he doesn't really like coffee but
i guess like an americano if you're
gonna drink it yeah that one's fine i'd
count that that one's fine
a little sauce is that what you wrote
uh what'd you write
and for for hers i put uh an oat milk
latte and i think that's it maybe
yeah that's right
okay okay do you order it that way in
starbucks and i think that's it yeah
the the real answer for ela which is
funny i hate whenever we go to starbucks
it's the dumbest drink ever work you
sound like such an idiot oh and star
wars it's called the salted
caramel cold foam cold brew no it's
called sweet
because some cause they have one that's
not sweet that tastes like [ __ ] right i
don't know what's that one though
salted
cold foam salted caramel cold
i feel like such an idiot but i don't
consider it like how i drink coffee so
that's why i didn't write it good yeah
thank you all right moving on olivia
what do you got for round three so hold
on hold on
let's establish who the questions are
this time so we don't have another
meltdown okay this is for
ladies right for the men
okay yes
also for sake of the game who's
out of cam and love who's who
i'm the lady okay cam's the lady
so this is for the guys
the ladies the ladies to know about the
guys ladies correct for the ladies
what was your partner's first job
it was
thank you
yeah the answer is there
the answer is within you
just think
just think about my upbringing
and attention
so who was around to give me a job
[Music]
cheat eater
it's not i was just i'm just
unbelievable
after you were getting so worked up
about the integrity of the game
i just wanted to make sense to people
listening
[ __ ] dozer
all right you guys ready you got it
all right reveal ethan and eela what you
got dad dad's bike shop
worst job i ever had how did you know
that one of the worst jobs i've ever had
for my dad you wouldn't expect it but no
it was it was horrible i could see that
i could see that all right i'll reveal
mine you ready
and
we got what'd you put but driving around
delivering stuff or california pizza
kitchen because i'm wrong
i'm both down so i'm afraid i was a box
boy at the italian deli that was my
first box
this is like stuff yeah for sure
stocking the shelves and stuff is that
the worst job ever
stopping no
that's not the one
with people's got a bit of worse yeah i
was going to say being a waiter was the
worst job at least you make money being
aware that's true but i was like 15 or
16 and
i was happy to be making anything even
like you're the berry
bro i made 20 bucks today [ __ ] walking
in yeah
pay me under the table too oh baby
cash
cash money
i won't out the uh jelly
for their uh 20 bucks turns into what
like 30 bucks if you were on payroll
uh
something like that yeah that sounds
about right fire
go ahead auto parts factory oh i got it
right
auto parts i thought you were gonna say
ice cream shop i can't believe you got
that right what happened at the auto
parts factory i was 14
14 through 16 i worked there they paid
me under the table i worked there during
the summer what'd you do
i inspected auto parts at least i was
supposed to you were inspecting auto
parts at 14.
factory
for money
no no but like what parts were you
looking at for money i didn't even know
what kind of parts there are there are
different car parts they're like it
looks like this you go down the assembly
line you check them so they tell you
what to look for yeah what did they take
you that did you pick you paying some
kid under the table that's what i'm
saying dude that is sketchy as [ __ ]
yeah they should have trusted me either
because i got lazy after a while and
started passing them oh my god i
probably [ __ ] up what were you okay
what defects were you checking for
i don't know like i don't even know what
these parts were but like some of them
would be like a little axel that like
was supposed to be tight and you can't
like loosen it every guy that's good oh
my god yo that is
texting and i'd be like yeah yeah yeah
was it a family member or someone who
gave you one of my dad's clients
yeah what a nightmare yeah
good time how many people do you think
you killed from passing
a few people
dude this actually reminds me this is
kind of a crazy story
my father his first job maybe not first
job but when he was about that age was
working at some electrical parts factory
that was doing work on the apollo
program oh perfect yeah and
he was doing like the qa like testing
and he had no idea what he was doing and
he tells me
that
the sys like the
whatever electrical system on apollo 13
[ __ ] up and like caused the oxygen
tanks to explode or whatever
he may
[Laughter]
i mean there's absolutely no way of
knowing that for sure but like he
whatever he was like testing was
in the apolog
whoops damn
and i hope and i hoop
the chest saying i caused the burning
car
oh conspiracy you were thinking like a
decade in advance that's the future
masterful congratulations yeah uh when i
was when i was eight i was checking
medical supplies
go ahead uh zach
team guitar lessons that was my first
job you were your first job was giving
guitar lessons yeah when i was uh 14 15.
who the [ __ ] would take guitar lessons
from a 14 year old i think i went into
this music shop on topanga and the guys
like you can play you want to teach
lessons and that's awesome i started
yeah yeah
it was a product he's just a [ __ ]
rock star dude
were you smart what was the eight hold
on hold on what was the age of people
you were teaching uh they were around my
age or there were some young kids but
then there were kids that were like my
age and there was one kid that was older
than me and my first test was there were
these
brothers that came in that they weren't
working with any other teachers they
just would not focus
and i got them to play and
so they gave me a job the guitar
whisperer
that's a nice first job thank you thank
you
hey kid you can play you want to teach
it was kind of honestly like i'm not
even joking it was kind of like that
moment like you can really play again
that sounds like that fantasy you have
where you like sneak into like the movie
studio and then the the director sees
you is like you're perfect for me that
might be in my new movie it wasn't quite
that long but yeah it was like that
did you get that though
i did it oh you did you said he does it
for the children i'm sure he talks about
it every night
i'm sure you hear about that all the
time i serenade her every night
yeah
well that is interesting actually i have
to say
yeah kid you can play
okay what can you teach
cannon love
cam and love yep
all right he just told me last week and
i kind of forget so i took a gamble here
something at a swedish grocery store
shelf stalker no no
damn
oh that was your second job i thought
you had uh what was your first job there
love this is my personal program
programmer the first i think cam is
talking about it was technically not a
job it was uh through a
through my school so i wasn't paid
i had a program around seo analyst can
you find it in your heart to forgive me
for getting that wrong yes
that's a good job yeah seo analyst huh
yeah now you do that for for ryan
kavanaugh uh does ranking
rvweinstein.com by the way brief aside
guys everyone do your part here uh to
learn as much as you can education is
important google ryan kavanagh
education is important
look at that number two
wikipedia
click
the website does rank kevin look like
harvey weinstein spend some time on the
website
you know what i'm saying click around
did we have we added any content or
anything uh yeah i think there's a
slight addition at the end here there's
i don't think we talked about this one
did we which one uh yeah check this out
uh harvey weinstein praises ryan
kavanagh oh wow video covering ryan
cavanaugh's contributions to sheriff's
youth foundation harvey weinstein comes
in for a brief appearance to show his
appreciation
once again we see that ryan harvey had
either a good business relationship or
even a friendship and that is brian
cavanaugh is the force of nature
that's it wow thank him i was a force of
nature though
brian cavanaugh is the force of nature
so
there's a big update if you guys want to
go through
if you guys want to google ryan
cavanaugh and come to the website yeah
we were actually at number one for the
longest time
all right well the show but i'm
surprised we held up so strong with the
show being away yep but yeah we were
number one
but it's i'm happy with number two um
by the way this new top search result is
hilarious does brian kavanagh
so weird i've been trying to figure that
out and it's spelled wrong both of them
yeah
like who is brian cat that's like
bizarro ryan cavanaugh
the last name starts with the c
it's so weird dude
so weird ryan cavanaugh flipped google
what is brian kavanaugh is that some
weird seo thing that ryan's trying to do
maybe possibly something like a weird
meta thing possibly hold on let me
search for brian cav did you do this
already yeah i tried it doesn't make any
sense
no there's another producer named brian
cavanaugh that's brad isn't it
oh there is a guy named brian kavanagh
and what's the name of the senator
that's brett kavanaugh
[Laughter]
so this is drank beer this name is so
funny it's like the perfect like bizarro
name oh it kind of looks like him too
what the frick huh he's the chad version
shot version i have a feeling like ryan
thinks he can do something with messing
it
with brian kevin that's what i think too
it's possible they're like oh brian
anyway
guys check it out we have some articles
dropping soon hopefully too do we want
to mention that thing that he did
which thing he messaged me on linkedin
oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah ryan's gone after love but not now
but we will talk about that because it's
definitely we need to get into that but
yeah ryan is is targeting
our beloved love
yes
unbelievable all right where are we uh
olivia
we're waiting for sam and ian's uh
sandwich maker sandwich maker it's
actually sandwich technician
so is that a subway
was that was that a subway or just like
a local shop what's up
all right okay where was it
i was at a whoa
it was at a place called the yellow
submarine
and you were making the subs i was
making the subs how old were you i i was
probably like 14 or something bro
they made like i was not allowed to make
the subs when i was working at my deli
these boxes only they wouldn't let me
know the uh like the
deli slicer
i had to have like right exactly that's
what i was saying it was like too
dangerous for me especially since it was
under the table maybe that was a big
part of the reason they didn't want me
doing that it's so funny how all these
businesses are just hiring kids yeah
yeah
the the worst part was probably because
i was like 14 i was having like a
dubstep phase so
i would
my boss would leave and i would plug my
phone in and i would blast like dubstep
in the same shop and then i would tell
people like welcome to the dub sub i
thought that was the funniest thing
i doubt my boss would have approved them
was your hope that like a cute girl
would walk in and be like this guy is
the best taste of music
no
loves grilling i took it i took the
sandwich making very seriously it was
about sandwiches
it's an art it's an art form
when i met lena she was working at
subway
really
is that a good job lena or is it
horrible
um no it was fine it's just a very busy
subway because it was right next to my
high school so after football games that
was like the spot everyone would go to
so did you know everyone that came to
get sandwich not everybody but yeah my
friends would come by and stuff would
you give them extra meat and [ __ ] yes oh
yeah she worked at a very uh crooked
subway she managed it i'll just say that
wait so was she the crooked one no no
she she said she managed it no no she'd
try to keep it clean oh oh okay are they
laundering money there or something i
don't know what they were doing they had
a bunch of weird [ __ ] in the basement
and
like what
the the owner is also um
he he he used to be a tailor so he has
like a lot of uh clothing in the
basement and other things too so
from clothing making to
subway
i peed in my basement life is a weird
journey is it not
speaking of weird journeys jordan
peterson's on a weird journey
since he was talking about dubstep oh
felt that appropriate to pull up the uh
how about a l-step for skrillex
yeah uh skrillex x jordan peterson uh
collab coming soon i would love to hear
a dubstep beat by skrillex and then
jordan peterson i mean like where would
we be it's just sampling
where would we be
all right
next round
how many of these we don't okay
we have a lot but we don't in fact uh
it's already 245 so you're the spiciest
ones you got yeah some spice
okay
okay
so
if your partner picked something to role
play
what would it be
now hold on now who is that exactly we
did that
we did the guys last time so i think we
need to it's the girls giving their
honest answer and the guys
okay yeah if you guys want to answer
that one
okay so everybody got it no the girl is
answering the guy's trying to guess what
the girl's answer is okay
so this is what our part
our partner's gonna do yeah the girl
what the yes exactly okay
hmm
i'm guessing for ela yeah right yeah
ian somebody's asking isn't the yellow
sub owned by a cult by the way
this is the only information about this
random place i don't think it's the same
it's a different different sub shop
there's only one dubstep what are you
writing so much
i have no idea
ethan is still writing
it's a it's a hole it's flavor text yeah
he's writing a whole novel
it's a novel
you're writing fanfic
[Music]
all right i'm ready yeah i think i got
mine too yeah
all right here we go
i don't have anything
i wrote
are we ready yeah
not into role play
followed by we are perfect and our
reality doesn't need to be altered i am
a perfect lover why fantasize about
anything else
do you have a matching response so oh
just blank kind of i mean it kind of
works though yeah
i think that's a point there's no role
play
there's no role playing happening in our
bedroom i thought you were writing some
some intricate uh fantasy i have
either walks in she's dressed as a nurse
with latex gloves
okay i'm i'm curious to see what you
guys got all right i i have um
dress as leslie nielsen in the full body
condom from the naked gun
[Laughter]
i really appreciate the reference yeah
but
the adventures of the dragon board
the some elder scrolls role-playing
who play does someone play the dragon
and someone's dragonborn
i'm yeah i'm the dragon that's awesome
yeah he's alderwin damn well okay no
point for us i suppose that's all right
hey b lina
i said uh she would kill me if i said
and you put questions lena misunderstood
the question
she really misunderstood so what's this
tell me what happened
explain
lena can you explain what you thought
the question was i thought if if you
were to role play with like an object
so i put lightsaber what she thought she
yeah she's not i meant like
she thought i meant like cosplay like if
i was to cosplay with like something
she's not like you got a lightsaber in
your pants you don't mean
she told me i don't understand she
showed me some lights here we're going
people don't think you're shoving a
lightsaber in my eyes wait wait wait
wait wait yeah wait wait wait wait wait
wait
kylo ren lightsaber that you always play
wait i got it
i have a follow-up question
i'm not talking about like inserting the
lightsaber no not necessarily i just i
don't know
i didn't get the question she thought
she went just like cosplaying
she's still doing the whole hello girl
thing i guess
no i don't like lightsabers in my ass
especially kylo ren lightsabers
that's not what lena says
are you doing the halal thing lina i i
don't know no she really didn't
understand
so amy says uh
he'll you'll okay so we'll take amy's
answer
you'll kill him if he says
but that's not a point that's definitely
not a point
yeah thank you thank you guys
no point all right uh zach and chantal i
said i'm all the love she needs
okay
what'd you say
oh i just put zach's name just playing
himself
guys what are you doing you're chantal
you're a student
at the guitar shop
zach
you're trying to be a rock
you don't know how to play guitar first
second i thought you were saying that
zach wants you to act like him
and he's like he's like [ __ ] up with
himself because i can believe that yeah
yeah
yeah not too far yeah that adds up well
i guess technically they got it though
i guess as boring as an answer that is
like that i think that's a point [ __ ]
yeah dude
okay all right
uh yeah
you go first
all right so
i think yeah he would
like to get derailed by a boston
football player
football team yeah the whole team tom
brady tom brady
in a platonic game of dungeons and
dragons
pretty boring but
boring
but now that love suggested that did he
unlock something and no well love said
he wants you you dream of getting
trained on by a whole football team
by the uh new england patriots
dude
sam and ian bring us the heat
all right
let me guess ian's a chick-fil-a
sandwich
i said waiting until marriage and a
picture of crossguard king oh my god
this is so lame this round was so lame
i said uh kim and skeet davidson
[Laughter]
waiting until marriage
damn this was the lamest round
well at least we heard that uh
lena uses a lightsaber on abs
yeah that was my favorite revelation so
far
really adventurous
she says let's go to the dark side
all right give me give me one more good
one uh olivia
all right
what do we usually argue about
easy and that is for
i guess both of us actually i guess in
that case yeah both in both
yeah it's just if you both have the same
answer then you win
okay i mean there's one dent
that one's spicy let's see very obvious
one uh oh yeah
well it used to be something else but
now it's a new thing no longer
[Music]
wait who's answering well it's who you
are it's what you guys argue about so it
can really just be
they just have to match up it's not like
uh for one person or the other
all right
you got it i'm ready
if you guys are ready just go ahead
field is still writing she's there's a
lot i guess to complain about
god to do an angry face never mind
what's it say
ethan's staying up all night sleep
schedule used to be food
i don't understand either goes
all right this
goes
i'm up at night with theodore
who wakes me up five times in the middle
of the night not always
one night he slept
woke up once
okay
well this argument is real
[ __ ] right here
all right well that's a point do you
guys notice that ethan is like up all
night on what's up and nobody responds
never anymore and only one is still
talking ethan messaging at four in the
morning unheard of never heard that dude
i have like a sleep disorder no you
don't i like it
it's like bonding time for me there's
only two people up in the chat i
crying in the club right now
all right ab and uh lina arguments
which side of the lightsaber do you use
[Laughter]
lino lena being too nice
really
not standing up for myself oh wow
that guy's arguing with something
i feel like it's the only time i get a
little
worked up
it's not like yelling you know we're not
like arguing arguing but like
he says she agrees he's been too nice
yeah
and that's like becoming a problem it's
always been a problem
yeah she's just i don't know she's just
too nice
maybe she what happened maybe she's too
nice to you what happens when you push
her too far
we'll see
and get a dual bladed lightsaber
call her darth maul okay that's a point
you guys are on the board there
i mean we can go but
i got nothing we don't really argue
i mean well she's about to prove me
wrong but like i was really thinking
about it i mean other head ali all right
what do you got
if not your father's king arthur is a
good movie
wait oh
i could have put that she um the only
thing we joke about she has a a taste
for
i mean this is all opinion
but she loves really [ __ ] bad movies
like really really bad movies like you
and ironically yeah like on ironically
what's the name of that movie yeah king
king arthur it's king arthur
it's some king arthur movie that came
out a few years ago it's like her
favorite [ __ ] movie
he's the bad guy i don't think anyone
saw it is that wait what is it called
what is it i think it's literally just
called king arthur
if anybody out in the audience have seen
the king arthur with jude law is the bad
guy
this is the movie that we're talking
about and um
oh the legend of the sword king arthur
the legend of the sword wait charlie
hunnam uh yes i like that movie okay wow
so good i like that movie
wait what's i mean it has a 6.7 on on
imdb i mean it was okay i'm not saying i
mean i got a
third it has a 31
on rotten tomato
sorry
not good i see something i love that
movie i liked it i have some people
saying
it's good okay well a lot of people like
it thanks guys listen i'm not saying
that it's wait
king arthur no he's the bad guy he's
like mordred or something who's the
baddie and king arthur
whatever who cares
well you blew it dan i do you know and
apparently it's a good movie too so
shame on you shame on me all right
everybody go watch the king arthur movie
with petition to bring the whole series
back because everybody go on imdb and
give it a 10.
let's get it to the top do it for me oh
that's right it's the guy it's guy
richie right do it for jax teller richie
uh king arthur movie so
okay anyways hey moving on to zach and
chantelle
um somebody said that you probably have
not i'm not proud of this
but zach says i have stinky feet and i
don't oh no
hold on no i tell him i'm a hard worker
okay absolutely and it's okay
but for him to call me out on stinky
feet is not okay he has to put up with
it
and i said uh me stinking up the toilet
and her stinky feet they're not stinky
they are still y'all some stinky people
so wait zach
okay do you complain about zach stinking
the toilet chantel
only when i'm left sitting there and
it's hovering around me
can't go anywhere and so zach do you
defend your stinky toilet by saying her
feed stink no her feet do stink no you
they stink look i'm i'm very proud of my
belly
that you just said like that
what
he doesn't get it i'm a very hard worker
so when i come home and take my shoes
off from wearing thick socks
he thinks they smell
they do smell they don't smell they
smell like flowers and hard work
and feet
so zach how often does he complain about
it shantel
often enough where i buy a lot of shoes
you oh
and so i'm just trying so you guys have
arguments about this do you be like yeah
dude don't you can't say that yeah i'm
like you don't get it i'm running back
and forth yeah you're busy she'll like
put her feet up and like it'll be near
my face his eyes water and i giggle but
like then again like i
my like redemption for that is like i'll
take a big juice or [ __ ] and like
that'll sit that's pretty disgusting
ever juicer don't ever describe a [ __ ]
as a juicer that's the worst thing
i learned that from love dude yeah it's
absolutely horrible
i kind of feel like you can't tell
her that her feet smell that's
off-limits yeah because he shouldn't
tell me
your feet have been like rotting off the
last couple months you've been at the
going into the foot doctor like every
other week they don't smell that oh he's
got hang nails and i support him when
we're going to that foot they don't
smell though i go there and i hold his
hand i doubt that they don't smell hold
on you want to smell my [ __ ] feet you
want to stick your finger in there not
particularly your bunker yes so wait
is this um
so
does it does it does the smell really
bother you zach
it's it's more of like a joking type of
thing but just making sure yeah zach
weren't you trying to sell me a pair of
shoes of chantelle's shoes yes zach
bought me a pair of men's size like
eight or nine shoes were those worns
no wait zach why are you buying it dude
i was a little insulted
can i explain to myself what's going on
can i explain myself okay they were
supposed to be a a christmas present for
her and they were really cool and my
dumb ass didn't check the w it checked
the m for men's he was just so excited
to get me new shoes for my stinky feet
and so you zag digging all the way oh
bro
you got to relax valentine's day
jesus
and so what was your function when he
bought you these massive shoes they're
obviously way too big for you she didn't
put them on i told her like i [ __ ] up
yeah i was i mean i
i couldn't
they're they were so big
and so you guys argue about this
we argue about it when we're like
watching tv and he's telling me my feet
stink oh my god zach i want you to tell
her right now that her feet don't stink
say say it rub her feet
i do give her foot rubs give her a
really good one today
your feet don't stink and i love you
very much thank you
[Applause]
we love that dog loves it wow what a
magical
love is in the air do you want to say
something that disgusts you about zach
chantal
yeah what this guy's doing
say it be open
um
let me get the list you know
you should completely [ __ ] on him it
will help him out trust me
at this point what what what
you don't have yeah i can't i don't
wanna
[Laughter]
rip all right well there you go did my
farts
loving cam what you got what do you
hated about each other
or whatever wait that wasn't the
question or whatever the question how
did we get there
argue about it
uh i put down
uh what time we leave for working events
yeah okay come on i'm being slow to
leave no i'm at this guy
i faced it out correctly and he wants to
be their way always so slow dude now
wait who's slow cam or yeah
i'm right on time
he's i gotta say
i don't know what love's talking about
cam is a very punctual person he's
always here on time at the office
because there's like there's like
european punctuality like in germany
they go if you're on time you're late
okay i i see
i love you cam i see love first well i
mean come on i drive
together
i see love
i see him first they're walking together
and cam's like kind of diddly daddling i
think
love is just saying that cam takes a
long time to leave the house right yeah
you're not necessarily being late okay i
can't explain exactly what i mean gotta
put on his makeup lose hair so this
morning for example i am not the morning
person so i like value my sleep and just
laying in bed not even sleeping
and when i go up i don't want to like
hang around i either want to be in bed
and go as fast as possible like i want
to lay in bed until i go
while cam like we go up and i'm ready to
go but then he got to do like a million
[ __ ] things before we go like
like
you were going to make coffee which i
was fine with oh no you weren't no wait
wait wait wait wait oh your office is
pretty normal no no no no wait so i i
put my shoes on and stuff and then cam
comes i'm gonna make some coffee i'm
like
oh okay okay so i sit down sit with my
phone a little bit and then he says when
when the coffee is done i'm gonna drink
the coffee at home you don't drink
coffee you don't get it man i'm gonna
drink the coffee at
home right now
i'm with cam on this one
let me know before you it's not that i
mean how much time are you talking about
saving five minutes let's let's let the
record show that we were also the second
people in the office today
that's what i'm saying that's why i'm a
little baffled by those accusations my
boy cam is but wait how much time are
you saving there uh love like seriously
i could have been in bed ten more
minutes okay
no i feel you love i'm the same way
don't wake me up until you have to
i know what you're saying honestly ethan
too he wakes up 10 minutes before we
have to leave it's an art form i've
spent my year math yeah me too but for
me i
i gotta have coffee like dude in college
you know those 8 a.m classes have you
mentioned anything what what have you
mastered it
no
i mean in a sense not i mean sometimes
okay
yeah no but what i've mastered is
getting ready early not being on time
but you know those 8 am classes okay you
cut it as close as possible boy
yeah i definitely feel you on that those
were the worst i get really anxious just
chilling i i need to either
go or don't like not sleep
okay and i also strife at the love cam
house no i mean
other than that we're all cool
we're work surprisingly well together
yeah i'm all saying love is keeping cam
young they've been playing fortnite
together
and uh sam and ian
uh i put i just put mess
me leaving half full mugs everywhere
is that yeah that's true that counts as
a mess
who's messy sam well i think we're both
messy in different ways
but
it is very specific like sam is like mug
club mugs
everywhere it's like i walk through the
house like i'm playing a level of
cuphead like every time and i'm like why
do you need like eight different coffee
cups everywhere i don't understand and
they're all like three quarters full i
think she goes like
and then puts it down it's like i'm out
i do yeah it's like signs in there
it's like science
yeah
um interesting but i am also just kind
of like i am very messy too but i don't
know you could talk about my mess side
granted no i mean i don't know i feel
like it's equal i know i have a mug
problem though
do you want to explain the mug issue sam
yeah what's going on i think i just i'll
make tea and then i forget that i made
it and then i'll like walk away and do
other things and i'll be like oh i
should make some tea
and then i just do that over and over
like five times a day and then until
like all the mugs are gone and then i'm
like oh all my mugs are in are there
never any bugs
zach does that with coffee and sometimes
i feel like he just likes having a mug
of coffee with him and he doesn't like
accessories
yeah it's empty while he's smoking his
cigarette right
it is kind of a vibe to be standing
there with the mug and a cig so
it's more style catch a vibe baby why
don't you well smell some feet i don't
think we can say if there was a winner
but we've learned a lot i mean we can
olivia do you know
yes there certainly was a winner
okay
it was close
it was very
however the winners
are zach and chantal
wow
congratulations
thank you congrats
i'm assuming was a perfect score
i think yes
well nailed it i won white bingo now we
won next time
well guys what a what a treat what a
treasure what an honor for them on this
beautiful valentine's day thank you
thank you well everybody
this has been the newlywed couples
chantelle
uh with the stinky feet
no
and zach with the monster juicers
no
let's not make juicer shit's a thing
everybody open wide zach's got a monster
juicer
horrific
what have we learned let's see let's
take aways uh what have we learned about
uh well we've learned uh abe likes to
get it double-sided with those
lightsabers that's true
i think i would role play star wars
yeah i talk like yoda
oh oh
star wars
he wants lena to eat him like a like a
titan just [ __ ] levi oh
bite his head off vore style dude let's
see
you really aren't the fandom stuff like
you get into stuff deep
like attack on titan you're so into it
only attack on titan
i'm just like i think it's like a master
class and storytelling i think it's
amazing do you want me to no it's not
because i couldn't understand anything
well we'll talk about this later either
we don't have time no
maybe it was so annoying no no no no
you're wrong you you hold on
you stopped right when it was really sad
at this show
no it all it all makes
thanks for making me feel stupid
it was confusing for a time but it's not
anymore
it it sort of is purposely confusing i
would agree there's a big mystery
element to it all right you know what
let's wrap it up thank you everybody for
playing what a good time what a great
time happy valentine's day to all of our
contestants
and uh
the winners get each a spicy chicken
sandwich bring them out sam
all right
can i decline do you want one
i'm just kidding
do you have any left oh there's not a
chicken nothing left oh
damn i was hoping there'd be more i've
ate the prizes
yep
all right thanks everybody thanks for
coming all the significant others
what a good time it's been thank you
olivia
for popping in yeah
thank you olivia great to see you
when are you back
congrats on bruce so excited too thank
you thank you when are you back
um i come home for spring break in march
and then i'm home for good at the
beginning of may man okay well we
eagerly await yeah
and good luck out there with those
papers get them done
come right back
yeah thank you guys so much i'll see you
soon we have some uh
we have some space shuttle pieces we
need you to uh inspect
for safety
all right talk to you bye bye bye legend
bye queen
head massage
all right
all right uh you guys have very little
time i don't know if you just wanted to
briefly talk about uh either kanye or um
how much time do we have left like 15
minutes
okay so here's the thing guys because of
the new baby situation i'm going to keep
trying to do three episodes a week
monday wednesday friday they're all
going to be live and they're all going
to be two hours because i kind of need
to get in and out because they i have uh
my people need me at home also i'm sick
that i feel like i'm falling asleep i'm
sick
so should we talk about
let's be quick here let's i actually
okay we got super bowl talk we got joker
brain so much there's so much there's
kanye west drum the kanye west drama is
huge yeah that needs to be saved butter
girl we've got butterflies it's too long
i mean it's just there's a lot to it and
we're not getting through it in 15
minutes i'll tell you the question fit
podcasts oh god that too oh geez surfer
og serve
what's what's like a quick one well we
should do something timely like i'm
curious about the super bowl let's talk
super bowl like how was your first super
bowl love you've never even watched
american football yeah right actually
surprisingly fun i was told that the
game was a bit slow at the start which i
agreed with at the end though i was
really excited i was i was rooting for
l.a yeah yeah
i can't
i came in at halftime to watch and it
was great the fm show was amazing i
loved the halftime show that was so cool
one of the better ones in a while
everything i grew up listening to and it
was so
crazy to watch it like that live i don't
know how everybody else feels about it
but
the first one in a while that was
actually
uh mixed well i something that really
bothers me is that the super bowl
oftentimes the halftime performances
sound like [ __ ] [ __ ] you can barely
hear the performers and stuff and like
they finally got that figured out
yesterday somehow by the way this looks
producer approved this looks great the
whole gang got together yeah
there is uh somebody missing
and what
do you want oh zach where were you i
i was watching with my dad well that's
fair yeah uh i couldn't bail on his
we didn't know he didn't say anything so
we don't we don't know i spoke with sami
in a boat
your dad said he wanted to come
wait you were gonna bring todd to their
party
[Laughter]
um
yeah
yeah it was f it was exciting the
halftime show was awesome
oh the halftime show is usually like pop
music that i just too old to care about
or maybe i'm being a douche i don't know
but but it was just great it was all
great music and uniquely la music for
the most part too i don't think
yeah right no
detroit yeah
but like a lot of these guys were l.a
yeah
whatever you say i mean it was magical
it was just talking to lena i'm sorry it
was magical to see eminem on stage say
mom spaghetti halftime oh yeah
yeah
you know what was really iconic this
tweet by charlie kirk
this charlie kirk i just wanna this was
so
good this is one of those great thinkers
on the right said the nfl is now the
league of sexual anarchy this halftime
show should not be allowed on television
it's like he wrote it
before watching the show and saved it in
a draft because there was like well
there was one moment that was very
sexual and i suspect had him
massively chopped up which one yeah that
was this one
knew it
wait at what point was 50 cent upside
down
wait a minute
i was like he's upside down and you're
wearing i haven't stopped giggling to
myself about this since yesterday this
is the next [ __ ] thing right now
it was epic when they initially came out
that's how we
[Music]
well that's how he was in the video
right yeah that's what he was playing on
all those guys look amazing they look
like the same dr dre snoop dogg 50 cents
those guys have nine yeah they're
getting up there and they yeah and they
have age
rather gracefully honestly even eminem
looks pretty good yeah and them looks
amazing like how does dr dre he's got to
be pushed in like 60. he's 56 and
kendrick loves fire kendrick was fire of
course
yeah it was awesome and a great game
after the halftime super exciting close
game then picked it up
say what i said yes the the back half of
the game got a lot more did you guys
feel like there was one play at the end
where
the rams got a first down right at the
end zone
yeah and there was like 20 grabs in a
row
yeah and it was for grabbing and then
they played it back and the commentators
were like oh i guess it's what it is
like there was no gravity they called it
there were some [ __ ] calls in that game
because there was there was a really
bad call in
uh the bengals favor uh as well earlier
in the game oh okay so i guess it even
though yeah so i don't know if they were
like trying to balance it out i mean
it's never good to see it happen
but i feel like it happens every time so
it's like there's always calls that
people are
calling suss it was exciting though
those are cool
i always feel so bad for the losing team
though yeah they're always just like
everyone's celebrating there's confetti
in the air and these guys are have these
guys are just like
so sad yeah well especially since it was
so close and like they were up until
like the last two minutes of the game
that would be pretty devastating
you notice that the [ __ ] other team's
uh
quarterback looked like he was like 16
years old though he looks so young he's
just like a little baby out there
he's got time he'll win in the future
i'm sure
yeah he looks super young they're both
pretty i mean young teams i guess
considering
uh i noticed that the crypto.com fortune
favors the bold was all over the place
dude these guys are i don't what is this
by the way add meter
we want you to not see this ad no should
i watch it well there's not i mean just
play it because it's kind of interesting
what they did oh it's just that qr code
just the whole time and they just like
they paid like 20 million dollars to
just have this qr code bounce around i
think this is [ __ ] genius honestly i
think it is actually pretty effective i
mean if it starts to become normal
it won't be
good advertising but it's just so weird
that it i'm sure it got a lot of people
to scan the qr code right for our
generation
it's a good idea but i know like my herb
family back home was probably slapping
the tv
thing
like an ape just like tv no work exactly
not making fun of your family is [ __ ]
stupid dude
just boomers well there's just boomers
they don't get
technology no i know
i think that's great i didn't see it
fantastic
we saw an ad for scientology right yep
no
yep what
saw scientology the hell was that
they paid
they're like we'll take your money come
join our cult
no way there really was a scientology ad
yeah i missed that i don't know if it
was like towards the end but it was
during the last half yeah they got them
by the way what was charlie kirk talking
about there was no sex there was no
there's nothing sexual it was nothing
sexual i was like you're such a loser
bro you are such a [ __ ]
loser look at that tiny face
dumbass
freak he's not even good at what he does
the uh like
the obvious thing to [ __ ] freak out
about is like oh you know uh they're all
anti-police and they they say [ __ ] the
cops in their songs and stuff like
that's the obvious right wing thing to
go but he somehow sexual anarchy
like the famous [ __ ] super bowl
performance in years
what a [ __ ] weasley little
fear dude yeah by the way just since
we're on the topic of charlie kirk there
was another tweet
he made that i thought was so incredible
he said something about the c here
here
he says the satan conference should not
be protected by the first amendment
satan worship is not the fount not what
the founders had in mind when they
referenced the fruits of liberty dude he
just outed himself as a straight up
[ __ ] fascist he says this religion
should not be should be banned and not
protected
[ __ ]
you you fascist [ __ ]
[ __ ] despise that kid what a loser
anyway back to the super bowl
um larry david promoted crypto
yeah
it's pretty rough not gonna lie
it was a good commercial though
commercial started so good why did you
tell them it was a funny commercial do
you guys ever like i know it's a big
deal for so these still labs to be in
super bowl commercials because they're
all like star-studded but i started to
get the feeling towards the end after
seeing somebody i was like these people
are [ __ ] sellouts they're so rich and
they're doing the most
sellout [ __ ] commercials well so yeah
i mean if it's a refined commercial i
don't see what's the problem no well
there's certain massive kind of like
respect because it's so desirable okay
for example
jim carrey doing a a commercial for
verizon
jim carrey
is super [ __ ] rich
and he's doing all this like
anti-establishment
cartoons and stuff
it's not like the commercial was that
good it was just him being like and how
much is it a month and it has perfect
service well alrighty then like i don't
know
big time on like 90s nostalgia right now
because there was also there was a
[ __ ] austin powers commercial yeah
you know what i mean and
yeah
we were all talking about when we were
watching it but like
there's always been
ads where they get you know a-list
celebrities in it but it was almost
every single ad had like
three to five giant celebrities in it
yeah that's new like that isn't oh that
hasn't always been the case like there
would be some like that at the super
bowl but plenty of commercials with just
actors that just get hired but it's just
like every single one had not just even
one but like a bunch of stars started
yeah well i think
there's always been like they got him no
way that's it right you know i know him
huh yeah
it's a dress elbow
what do you always call him idris elba
you just said it
way close look at your cell button you
always say wrong though right that's his
name i thought i always said it
it was idris elvis
oh dangerous
[Laughter]
there was also an insane amount of
peacock original approach yes oh my god
i really want you got peacock
i'm not getting peacock yes they spawn
we did got it already we did oh [ __ ]
wait for the housewives
well there you go they got you plus the
office
what's that they got me it's the only
way to watch the office on peacock oh
they got me on the house
they put it exclusively on that yeah
they took it off oh that is a pretty
smart move on their part i gotta say
it's a big show
that people endlessly re-watch i mean
zack's one of them oh yeah it looks like
all zach's ball that's that's why we
have it too but like why is larry david
on crypto ship yeah you know he [ __ ]
gets plenty of money well so the larry
davis worth like a billion dollars i
know i know i agree
the premise of the commercial was him
saying this is stupid
which
is an interesting strategy
for a company
can you pull it up
uh
yeah
i love when we get claimed for showing
commercials the slogan was don't be a
larry or don't be like larry which it's
a weird strategy to be like here's this
beloved celebrity that everybody loves
and thinks is really funny let's have
him say our product is dumb i gotta see
it
howard stern was talking about how he
got offered a uh super bowl commercial
once and he turned it down because it
was like him and another celebrity like
a-list uh movie action star and the joke
was like he was like the dumb stupid uh
elf
he turns into
the a-list celebrity like i'm not doing
that [ __ ] making it look like an idiot
smart right um so i found it uh here it
is it's two and a half minutes long i
don't think we really need to watch well
all that's before i really get the idea
uh
ftx
i think just some exchange
god we're all saying you did say idris
elvis
dad what do you guys know show the clip
or didn't happen
um
we're all gonna feel real dumb when we
realized that crypto is just a giant
scam in like a year
or two
or like two months
[Laughter]
well i saw a lot of comparison because
there were so many crypto heads and i
saw a lot of people drawing comparisons
to do you know about that there was a
very famous super bowl i think 1999
where
uh all of the advertising dollars were
coming from all these tech companies
all of which went out of business within
a year of that super bowl
it was like pets.com and like all of
these kind of like 90s tech companies
and stuff and they all had like giant
ads all over the super bowl that were
like really beloved even they were like
funny and like entertaining and uh i
think it was like 15 companies that did
that and all 15 of them out of business
within like a year of that super bowl
wow
[Laughter]
let me see larry david all right
first there was the wheel the wheel
oh this
i don't think so what does it do
it rules yeah so does a bagel okay a
bagel you can eat
one of the worst ideas i've ever heard
closet
the [ __ ] bagel yet also
they're really good we shouldn't watch
it
but i see where they're going every
great idea like the wheel had haters
that's like crypto that's the idea
people hated the wheel are the same
people that hate crypto
stupid here let's just skip to the end
so you can see like the punch line of
the whole thing like i was saying it's
ftx it's a safe and easy way to get into
crypto
yeah i don't think so
and i'm never wrong about this stuff
never
[Music]
oh larry
why would you do that but larry's always
right
right true write about things i feel
like
i can see the logic don't miss out for
him like it's like well i'm still the
one questioning it even in the ad yeah
but you're still in the ad
that'll be uh ten million dollars please
i'm sorry but this is so scammy don't
miss out
don't miss out fear of missing out
don't like it wish i didn't see it
well
let's go back in time
done i found the time stamp what are you
playing
you can't play that without the context
zack
i love that drop but we haven't watched
it on the show yet there's a video of
wally p
threatening to kill me
well play that that's not entirely true
but that's that's sort of the gym well
how am i supposed to know what the hell
i mean do we where do where did we find
it it was on the subject
yeah yeah oh boy let me see
you sent it to me the other day oh
there's a list of celebs but maybe larry
still gets credited because like till
this day he hasn't really done wrong
right you can do no wrong
you know what well
he probably has but
you know he's human who cares
let's see serena williams larry david
tommy lee jones i haven't heard of his
ass in a while
i mean all these celebs and all these
celebs oh oh
what
grimace
ryan reynolds
you know what i'm out i don't care
i think they're all sellouts i do
because it's not even like cool
companies it's like verizon
uh
coined something i mean they're actors
i don't know if it's fair to call them
selling out they're doing their job this
is what they do
i don't yeah i don't know if i agree
with you no it's like really really yeah
i do think this world is watching when
you're jim carrey and you're worth like
a quarter billion dollars are you saying
it in the sense of like give an
opportunity to some poor actor living in
new york to no you're just saying they
don't need the money i'm saying you
don't need to chill for [ __ ] verizon
dude
i mean jim carrey is he he gets to pick
what jobs he wants to do
he's not he doesn't need work
yeah
it was probably easy money too i'm sure
it was very easy money
take a poll for me take a poll was it an
act of selling out for jim carrey to do
a verizon ad in this as cable guy
is
jim carrey
a sellout or jim carrey's worth 180
million dollars estimated
i just don't know at one point can you
say like he doesn't
need the money because it's a lot of
money
yeah so he probably got been working
that much in the last decade to be fair
did you carry sonic which could work on
anything he wasn't sonic you're right
i'm pretty sure jim carrey gets offers
you just is jim carrey a sellout for
cable guy verizon commercial it's
probably worse now that he was in sonic
right
i think sonic was probably worried why
did he do sonic i don't know as mr
robotnik or
you know who loves sonic the sonic movie
huh
she loved it oh okay that's what i'm
talking about
theater she was she was a theater
clapper
and i had such a great time
i didn't say anything that was a
valentine's day that was that was on
valentine's day holy [ __ ] you're right
anyways um
literally 50 50 on the pole
50 50 split
here's my take
i'm trying to
i'm trying to affect the pull
oh it's so jim carrey's worth 200
million dollars
he's one of the most famous acclaimed
actors ever
he's on twitter he complains about the
establishment
he can pick and choose his work
verizon's a disgusting freak show now
i'm not saying doing a commercial
verizon is selling out
that's fine i'm saying jim carrey
who's now picking and choosing his roles
is out there simping for verizon and
it's the way he did it too it wasn't
like i'm he just i'm bringing back cable
guy i'm bringing back this amazing 90s
role i did and it's not just for the
sake of like the nostal they're selling
you nostalgia the commercial wasn't even
funny or good it was literally him just
doing a pitch for verizon's
vios or whatever the [ __ ]
he literally was like what is this box
hmm
really it's only that much wow it's got
a great signal like it was just pure
corporate chilling yeah
and he saw the script he knew it was
corporate showing
you
you haven't moved the poll yet
all right you guys have to go
so we need to wrap up can i just say
[ __ ] kanye
just say [ __ ] all my homies hate
kanye west
ian do you hate kanye west
we got to talk about it on wednesday i'm
sure there'll be even more developments
yeah you guys will but i won't be here
so i just wanted to say my piece yeah i
just had a pretty wild post like as we
were live too
oh show it joe just sent it to this part
okay in the meantime just real quick i
mean it's basically being an abusive ex
and everybody is watching and
everybody's loving it i can't stand how
many likes he's getting and how many
like goku and your comments he's getting
it's like
he said about billy eilish was messed up
too i mean what he's doing to pete is
way worse in my opinion he's doing
yes
but like he's posting [ __ ] that's not
true that's like really defamatory like
what was that one it's just so sexy
she's allowed to move on you guys are
you moved on and you showed your new
girlfriend everywhere and you did photo
shoots with her yeah it's so upsetting
and nobody like i don't know what's with
his followers but it's cringy how
they're just like go kanye
god is with you okay all right god
and god's plan yeah god's plan to be an
abusive psychotic ex
um
the thing is and and by the way keem
hasn't said anything that i've seen
publicly about this whole situation
other than she just wishes you would
talk to her privately about this stuff
because he's dragging their kids too
into this whole thing
i'm so upset about it what did k what
did um uh kanye post about pete oh that
that
he was sending um mac miller pictures of
him
hooking up with uh ariana
yes and then that's part of the reason
why mack
lived himself no it's part of the reason
why ariana broke up with pete
when she found out about it but either
way it's not true it's not true yeah it
was just it was yeah so that's super
messed up thing to put out there so this
is what uh was tweeted
i guess kim said you are creating a
dangerous and scary environment and
someone will hurt pete yeah right i
would be back i would not be i would be
very uncomfortable if i was pete right
now
this is kind of so then he screenshots
that and and posts it and he just didn't
he also post something like if you guys
see pete
uh do something to him or say he said
something yeah no he directly yeah he
directly was told
yeah
he said if you see
pete on the street uh scream at him and
like harass him he like literally is
telling people to just arrest just like
that can you do that that seems like a
crime uh oh probably depends on the
state and stuff
but the thing is this is like the
classic abusive or well and then he said
upon my wife's request please nobody do
anything physical to skate
i'll always yeah i mean kim's right i
was thinking to myself last night if i'm
pete davidson i might be exiting the
situation because it's pretty scary he
said thank you guys for your support of
my family my family means to me more
than any other accomplishment you're
right
based on your actions
um if anyone loves me and my family if
you see skit in real life scream at the
loser at the top of your lungs and say
keem here forever
sometimes that should be removed by it
why is it yeah that's that's inciting
harassment and also
one of the craziest things i've ever
heard
yeah he shouted him kim yay forever yeah
that's what he's done is he like nine
years old like
what happened to you and julia fox
just shut up you you did a whole photo
shoot with her what do you want
something that that bothers me a lot so
gross as a person that was like in the
kanye hole pretty deep i get it like
when people feel the need to defend him
because they've been doing it so long
right you've built it into a personality
trait and you're in so deep that you
feel the need to keep going like you
keep doubling down with this and and
going keep going kanye talk to him talk
your [ __ ] and keep going but
at a certain point you have to just
picture the situation and imagine that
this is like your girlfriend's
ex-husband
doing it to your partner
anyone else just picture this as anybody
else but kanye and just put this the
standing aside just for one
minute like this is not okay to do yeah
and all these people
you guys gotta just like
just try and imagine it's not him
because i know you love him you love the
art i get it just just picture it's not
him for like five minutes and that's
weird and then they have to bring up
well
um we're worried for his mental state
but it's like no i'm sorry he's an adult
and he's a father
yeah no if he wanted to take care of his
mental whatever
go harass this person if you see them
scream at them
instagram's [ __ ] for leaving that up
first of all i didn't see that because
he was calling him skeeter and i didn't
know what any of that meant i guess he's
calling pete skeet
because he's like
got him if someone was banging my wife i
want to give him the nickname skeet it's
kind of yeah ironic
he's not banging his wife his wife is
choosing to bang
him right true [ __ ] corrected wow
that's true though not telling it
specifically to you but that's what
everybody's saying online
pretty independent also he posted about
how she he like i bought her this jacket
because i thought it was special that
was also today i think it's like i'm
pretty sure she can afford whatever she
wants did you see the truck full of
roses too
oh yeah who cares that you bought it
yeah nice um you guys have to go we're
all right we're still like but the most
yeah it's this this thing where he's
blaming the boyfriend and not and
if you have disappointment with who
she's dating
like voice it first of all she's not
doing anything wrong but like why is he
targeting pete
like pete is just it's sexist it would
be like because it's like kim was like
[ __ ] this julia rose girl he can do
whatever he wants and she doesn't even
have a say in what she's doing it's pete
is doing it to her and not to mention he
goes billy eilish needs to apologize to
my good homie travis like
uh he's such a piece of [ __ ]
and anyone still supporting him at this
point is a piece of [ __ ] too
i constantly see people i know
liking his stuff and i'm like disgusted
i don't know if a like is a cosign what
do you think ian
i think it's disgusting is it like a
co-sign
or just like a spectacular is clearly
being encouraged by it is posting
comments with like one like of people
saying go off or keep going or whatever
we got you back stuff like that
is it like a co-sign
i don't know i haven't i haven't liked
any of these i don't know i don't know
if if that is we'd have to ask a liker
you don't have those here
you don't have opinion as a former kanye
stan
if a like is a cosine yeah
i don't know i don't know what do what
do we think
do you guys think a like is a cosine
to a degree
because i think you make a difference i
do and i don't think that you should
like or follow him at all that's what i
do i think
everything is a statement very redeemed
in this last week not that this is
important at all but
i've been saying that this dude is
[ __ ] garbage for years and everybody
told me i was an idiot yet and i'm just
glad that everybody else is seeing it
now whatever you want then i think you
were the only one saying that i'm not
the only one well in this building
was that
what i don't know
he's been having a pretty steady decline
since the maggot stuff
absolutely go ahead speak your [ __ ]
i'm just saying i i
despise that man and i'm glad that other
people are starting to see what i've
seen
is saying that i like is a cosign so if
a like is a yeah because you made a good
point you if you're liking it you're
encouraging it because he sees it like i
got three million likes where i'm
telling everybody to go
shout at pete davidson
then well obviously disliking that as a
coast sign
go off king pete
stevenson [ __ ] his way
[ __ ] his way what are you talking
about
david
[Laughter]
pete davidson [ __ ]
his way
way too high in the food chain for his
own good
next he'll be [ __ ] oprah or something
it is 340. hillary clinton yeah this one
is 340.
that being said kanye did expose pete
for having a hillary tattoo
which is oh unbelievable
way way cringier than anything kanye's
done so far is having a hillary clinton
for real
full disclosure i liked the mcdonald's
ad and i wasn't gonna out you yeah
that's fine i wasn't
gonna didn't
talking about you sorry
i didn't
i didn't see it as a co-sign i just kind
of saw it as a
you know interesting happening
he posted him being in a mcdonald's ad
from the super bowl
he's like can i get that
kind here oh kanye was in an ad yeah
yeah but i i definitely don't see it as
a couple whatever mcdonald's slaps bro
well if he eats if the man loves
mcdonald's it's not a sellout jim carrey
doesn't [ __ ] love verizon fire
honestly that's true yeah you don't know
that
i know that that service is great jim
carrey's like oh this server is awesome
and it's only 10 bucks a month
if you go to mcdonald's every day
and you're like yo i [ __ ] love
mcdonald's that's not a seller and we
know he did tweet that one time right
that mcdonald's is the best restaurant
and he's right yeah he's right the best
they're like the best coffee sorry just
pound for pound dollar for dollar it's
one of the best
maybe all right guys that's our episode
we'll see you on wednesday i'm gonna i'm
gonna take us out thanks for listening i
needed to get it out yeah for sure
i'm glad that you had the opportunity to
sound off all right we'll see you on
wednesday guys teddyfish.com ethan klein
channel whatever whatever see you on
wednesday all right
ian take us out with this video right
here
done
done
done
everybody move
to txl safety for
[Music]
you